y me acompaña en el estudio de nuestro
periodista deportivo 'juan piales juana
muy buen día bienvenido le pregunto cuál
es la primera lectura que se hace esta
presentación de lionel messi con su
nuevo equipo raúl lo primero que notamos
es que hay una especie de cambio de
mentalidad la última imagen que teníamos
de messi fue esa que vimos en la rueda
de prensa de despedida con el barcelona
completamente llorando roto desde hand o
al club que lo formó en el que se formó
como futbolista
aquí nos damos y vemos a un messi que ya
sonríe lo primero que dijo él en esa
rueda de prensa es estoy muy feliz de
haber llegado acá lo segundo que dijo es
estoy aquí para volver a ganar otra
champions él viene de vivir una
pesadilla completamente en la liga de
campeones la última que ganó fue en 2015
a partir de ahí vimos esa remontada
contra el liverpool ese 8 a 2 contra el
bayern él está muy centrado en volver a
levantar el trofeo que todos los
jugadores más anhelan esa liga de
campeones dice que está en el lugar
ideal para hacerlo va a tener a sergio
ramos- va a tener a wind that a wing
álbum va a tener algún aroma h rap el
lateral sensación de europa un verdadero
equipo para hacerlo y lo primero que
destacamos es ya verlo sonreír de nuevo
equipazo y como dices tú parece que la
tristeza le duro solo un par de días
pero ahora voy con la pregunta del
millón cuando será el debut de lionel
messi con el peso ya mes y viene de
jugar la copa américa y salir campeón
con argentina dice que él tiene que
hacer una pretemporada él solo para
recuperarse y ponerse a tono no quiso
dar ninguna fecha en concreto había una
especie de expectativa porque el pce yo
juegue ese sábado en parís contra el
estrasburgo por la ley andy y para ese
estadio después de 18 meses para ese
partido va a volver a haber un lleno
total de aficionados había una especie
expectativa sobre si ese sería su debut
en los equipos poner fechas dice que
tiene que volver a recuperar el tono
porque viene de vacaciones así en juan y
hay mucha polémica en torno a si el psoe
ya está rompiendo con el denominado fair
play financiero le pregunto que dijo su
presidente presidente del equipo así es
el presidente de nacer al khelaifi el
qatarí dijo que antes de cualquier
contratación lo primero que hace el club
es mirar si van a romper o no con el
fair play financiero dice que con el
caso de messi no se está rompiendo
ninguna norma le dijo a la prensa que se
centre en las cosas positivas acerca de
este fichaje para poner esto en contexto
el fair play financiero son las normas
de la uefa que establecen que un equipo
no puede invertir más del 70 por ciento
de sus ingresos la masa salarial del
equipo ni que tampoco pueden excederse
en el gasto de fichajes ese fue
precisamente el problema que sacó o que
hizo que el barcelona sacar a lionel
messi del barcelona porque el barcelona
tiene una deuda que supera el más del
100 por ciento en sus salarios dice 'el
veces ya que con el caso de messi que se
estima que ganará unos 45 millones de
euros brutos no se rompe esa norma y que
está todo en regla para poder ver a
messi con neymar y con mbappe en el
tridente ofensivo de ensueño lo que
sobra en ese equipo por supuesto es el
dinero juan muchísimas gracias por todo
el análisis de este fichaje de messi en
el psc